think sherry the idea of the whispering
announcers
and the softly clapping gallery we'll
call them the patrons like the masters
yes exactly well if you're not going to
allow
fans to be on the golf course watching
the game that i guess the squirrels
and the blue jays and the birds will
just have to be
the audience out there watching from the
trees
but what a cool experience i think it is
going to be neat
so hopefully it will be televised if
nothing else i don't know that we have
details about that either but
it's got to be it's just got to be it's
going to be really fun for the nights to
be out there for sure
all right well let's get to our mornings
our mornings have been
so chilly and we've got another really
cold morning out there
right now a beautiful shot as we look
across the high roller off to the east
side of town
a just a reminder again everyone that
we're on that one day a week watering
schedule
today's tuesday so that's the bee
watering group only nobody else
please have your sprinkler set for
daytime watering
if you're watering overnight or early in
the morning before day break
chances are you're going to have an icy
sidewalk or driveway and that can be
very dangerous
and of course no watering on sunday or
windy days you know these long long
nights that you might think that one day
a week is just not enough
but the problem is we're an exceptional
drought status right now for southern
nevada and no rain in our forecast
you can hand water whenever you want so
you might want to do that during the
daytime hours when it warms up we're
below freezing in seven
hills nellis the lakes is at 37
henderson you're at 35 it is cold we've
got
27 in trump out at red rock kingman this
morning
freezing in mesquite 34 in boulder city
and 48 in laughlin
this river of moisture is pouring into
the west coast
but of course it's got its aim just in
the pacific northwest
not for the desert so so much rain and
snow again
will be aimed at washington oregon and
northern california
while we get high clouds that spill into
southern nevada today
high clouds and sunshine that's our a
tuesday
with highs in the normal upper 50s so i
can't complain about normal
but we've got a warm-up coming as i've
been talking about this week mid-60s
tomorrow
even into low 70s near record territory
for the end of the week and into the
early part of the weekend
then we do trend the numbers down to mid
60s for mlk monday
we're